merci monsieur le ministre à paroles et
à madame marie louise fort merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
la cour des comptes présente aujourd'hui
son rapport public annuel sur la
situation des finances publiques
chaque année à la même époque c'est la
même rengaine
le rapport formule un certain nombre de
critiques et regrette que l'exécutif
n'ait pas tenu des critiques de l'an
passé que de temps perdu pour 2016 la
cour des comptes juge incertain
l'objectif de déficit de 3,3 pour cent
du pib en 2016 et rappelle les risques
qui pèsent sur nos finances une dette
publique élevée à déficit qui reste au
dessus des normes européennes et des
taux d'intérêt pour l'instant bas mais
pour combien de temps encore pour 2016
la cour s'inquiète d'une surestimation
des recettes et d'un risque de dérapage
des réponses des dépenses pourtant on a
vu que le président de la république
avait été fort généreux en annonces de
dépenses nouvelles lors de ses voeux on
retrouve comme chaque année une critique
sur la une critique sur la
sous-estimation pardon du budget des
opérations militaires à l'extérieur ou
de l'hébergement d'urgence ainsi que le
risque de dérapage des dépenses sociales
plus largement les sages vous appelle
une nouvelle fois engagé de vraies
réformes
après presque quatre ans au pouvoir vous
ne pouvez plus vous servir de l'excusé
du bilan en toute bonne foi vous devez
désormais répondre de vos résultats
or le constat de la cour est sans appel
prenons l'exemple des contrats de
génération votre remède contre le
chômage qui est le symbole de votre
échec sur le front de l'emploi
en effet ils n'ont en rien contribué à
faciliter le retour à l'emploi des
seniors et la cour juge ce dispositif
complexe et peu lisible et constate
qu'il n'a aucun de ses objectifs
échec sur le chômage des jeunes échec
sur le chômage des seniors échec sur la
transmission des savoirs quant aux
entreprises elles y voient au final des
charges supplémentaires inadaptées à
leurs besoins
votre échec sur l'inversement de la
courbe du chômage est patent les
différents dispositifs annoncés
changeront sans doute pas grand chose
puis je vous demander s'il apparaît les
cas monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget oui merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés
madame la députée marie louise fort
court après la cour des comptes
appréciera votre comparaison en disant
que c'est tous les essais tous les ans
le même refrain pense que nous avons
tous la même rengaine nous avons pour
notre part l'habitude de prendre en
considération les avis de la cour et
puisque vous avez cité les passages qui
vous intéressent je note que la cour des
comptes a d'abord estimé que nos
prévisions étaient atteignables madame
la députée atteignable et si les mots
ont un sens atteignable ça veut dire que
si l'ensemble des acteurs publics
je pense que chaque oeil à sa part la
majorité bien sûr l'exécutif bien sûr
une opposition aussi l'ensemble des
secteurs de la dépense publique la
sphère sociale la voyez vous que je
crois hier à se faire des collectivités
locales sur laquelle nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir
oui cet objectif de réduction des
déficits est atteignable
alors vous évoquez un certain nombre de
risques
il existe toujours des risques les
prévisions surtout quand elle concerne
l'avenir sont toujours incertaines mais
pour prendre l'exemple que vous prenez
sur les opérations extérieures de l'état
madame la députée de mémoire de
parlementaires tous les ans prise dans
caresse pourrait en témoigner
tous les ans les opérations extérieures
de l'état ont été assumés par un nous
prises en compte
interministérielle à la fin de
l'exercice et la réserve de précaution
est ainsi faite pour couvrir ce genre de
dépenses la norme de dépense a été tenue
en 2015 plus personne ne le conteste
elle le sera en 2016